[Music]
hello everyone
in the previous lecture we had uh
discuss some introductory statements
regarding the 3d elasticity chapter
and in the process of doing that we had
mentioned
that the intent
to ultimately take up the famous
historically important kelvins problem
now in order to do that
what we'll do is first introduce uh
the displacement with the mathematical
uh
of the displacement potential method
within this method there are a number of
different ways in which
the displacement vector can be expressed
in terms of
the in terms of potentials okay so
the idea is this that if i directly go
into the
the solution of the kelvins problem okay
the method or the particular way that i
have to take up
uh if i directly present that it will
appear to you like some kind of black
magic
okay so uh i mean without any motivation
or without
without the preliminary steps behind
behind that
that kind of representation which will
actually end up using there
uh you will be completely lost okay so
so the idea here is that we are first
going to discuss some general things
and slowly build up to a stage where
we'll be able to write down the kind of
displacement potential which will be
useful for the kelvins problem
okay so as the very first step was that
we note something
directly from mathematics which is
called the hemholes
representation theorem
the hemols representation theorem it
basically gives us
a recipe of expressing
a vector just like a displacement vector
but it is more general than that of
course because it's a mathematical
theorem
uh it gives us a recipe of expressing
a vector in terms of potentials and what
it says
we are going to present this theorem
without any proof
uh it's not that long that proof is not
that long but
uh i mean in the interest of keeping
things relevant
directly for the blood elasticity we are
not going to go into that
uh what it says is that any sufficiently
smooth vector field
in a sufficiently smooth vector field
can be represented
as the sum
of the gradient of the scalar potential
and the curl of a vector potential
so this part any sufficiently smooth
vector field that is basically giving us
an indication that
it should be properly differentiable
so some of the gradient
okay
some of the the gradient of the scalar
potential
and the curl of the vector potential
okay so so what is what is this telling
us in terms
of the displacement vector what are what
we obtain from this hemorrhoids
representation theorem
for our displacement vector
so when we have this displacement vector
what this hemos representation theorem
is telling us
is that this general displacement vector
no matter which problem we are taking up
this can be represented as
some grad of phi where this phi is the
scalar potential
and the curl
of a vector potential
please note that this phi is a scalar
potential
this omega this omega
vector that is a vector potential
okay so
let me write this here so phi is the
scalar potential
and omega
that's the vector potential
now you may think that what is this
because on the left hand side we had
we have these three unknowns the ux ui
used
in a rectangular cartesian coordinate
system and now on the
right hand side uh we have basically
four unknowns because this phi is
unknown and
the three components of this capital
omega
vector they are the unknowns so are we
going are we trying to make our life
easier or harder
well we'll see uh what are the
consequences
of of using this kind of representation
and and we can draw our conclusions from
that
all right so first of first a little bit
of discussion about
about the properties of this kind of a
representation
so first of all you note that this part
the grad of phi
this is what is referred to as the
irrotational part
this is the irrotational part of the u
vector
and what is the meaning of this
irrotational part it basically just
means that if you take the curl
just of this part if you take the curl
of this part
then this is zero please note that this
is
this is not an assumption or a
requirement this is true identically so
if you have any scalar potential
you take the grad of that and then you
take the curl of that this is going to
be true
this is going to be 0 identically
this part
this is referred to as the solenoidal
part
the name solenoidal it is basically
taken from its link with
electrostatics what it is basically
telling us is that
that it is divergence free divergence
free means if you take
the divergence of that part okay
so any so you know that this capital
omega vector is a
was a vector you take the curl of that
that also is a vector
okay so overall this is a vector so if
you have any vector and you say that
a vector is solenoidal it basically
means that if you take the divergence of
that vector
it is zero
okay that's it so again
you note that this is identically true
and you can take this up as a little uh
as a little
uh exercise for yourself uh
consider a general omega in the
rectangular cartesian coordinate system
for example
uh with components omega x omega y and
omega z
take the curl of that and finally take
the divergence of that result
you'll see that it identically comes out
to be zero you can do this yourself okay
we are not going to
invest any time on that now
what are the consequences of this when
we consider this this displacement field
through this rather complicated looking
representation it is find that out that
the mathematical theorem is
is telling us that this can be done but
so what okay it can be done
all right fine it looks nice very
mathematical but what is the use of this
okay so in order to understand the use
of this we have to uh
actually try to connect this with uh
with the with what we had been
discussing
in uh in the previous lecture at the
very end
so please note that our ultimate
goal here is to represent this stress
equilibrium equation
in terms of the displacement and then
to express that displacement or that
second order differential equation in
displacements
in terms of this potential and to see
what what kind of
things we can deduce from that okay
now
if we actually do these steps that
let me substitute the linear elastic
isotropic material behavior
for the sigma in terms of the strains
and then express the strains in terms of
the displacements using the
the strain displacement relations then
the
uh then the differential equation that
we are going to obtain
is basically this okay so you see
what i'm trying to do here is this
delta dot sigma plus
2p here equal to 0 from that
we are going to i don't need this arrow
there is a separate thing that i am
writing here
so from here what i will obtain is
delta dot u the grad of this whole thing
plus g
all right now
you see what i have here i actually have
my this displacement vector and i can
take the divergence of that
i will obtain some some expression using
in terms of this phi and capital omega
what about this del squared u
well it turns out that uh directly
taking the laplacian
doesn't do me much good here okay so
what i will do
is to uh
is to use a vector identity to
uh to transform this laplacian of u
this del square u uh into something
else okay and you'll see that that's
something else
which will will will actually be uh
involving
the curl of u uh
and we can we can actually uh
we can utilize some simplifications
involving these things
so uh in order to
avoid jumping between these expressions
and these expressions what i will do is
i will
first keep two results in my hand ready
first of all i will take the divergence
of this u vector
and then i will take the curl of this u
vector
and keep those two results ready in my
hand and then i'll come back to this
equation
and utilize those results so this is the
plan so let's go forward with this plan
so we write this u grad of phi plus
curl of omega
before launching uh into the into the
actual details of this
uh let me just point out that within
this chapter
okay so so all all throughout our
applied elasticity discussions
um starting in september
uh many of the discussions have been
quite mathematical in nature
and uh and the level of mathematics
that will be utilized in this uh 3d
elasticity
video elasticity chapter i think it is
the highest
okay as it is benefiting uh the last
chapter
that we are going to discuss so so
please brace yourself
it's not mind-bogglingly difficult
but you have to be a little bit careful
here okay
so with this preamble let us start with
the
details so divergence of u
so
this now
please note that uh we have already
mentioned that this part is solenoid
okay it is divergence free so this part
of course it is zero so
this is quite nice okay
now
what about the curd
we have this
all right again you note that we had
already mentioned that this grad of pi
is irrotation which means the curl of
that is zero that is exactly what we're
doing here we're taking the curl of the
grad of pi
and this is zero so immediately this
becomes
the curl of the curl of omega
now i don't want to leave it like this
okay so this is the part where i have to
first use my vector identity
and this is the same vector identity
which was which i was referring
a little while ago okay so you'll see
that we'll have to use this vector
entity
a few times so what is this vector
identity
so uh you can actually verify for this
yourself that what i'm going to write
next
is actually true uh so
we use this particular vector identity
which tells us
that the curl
of the curl of the vector please note
that this is a general vector identity
not just confined to this omega vector
but i am of course going to apply this
now on this omega vector which is why
i'm writing it like this
so uh this vector entity tells us that
the curl of
the curl of a vector that is
equal to the gradient
of the divergence of that vector
minus the laplacian of that vector
now uh this seems like
a rather hard thing to remember
okay now uh i mean you can kind of
remember it
uh through uh two words
and what you can think of it is it is
like the
the curl curl okay so the curl operating
on the curl
is equal to the
grad div so this is
divergence that that div represents the
divergence so it is the grad
gradient of the divergence minus
the div grad why is it different because
you see this laplacian
okay the laplacian is basically
equivalent to
the divergence of the grand of this okay
so this is the graph
you take the divergence of that so
divergence of grad
is the laplacian so curl curve is equal
to
gradient minus delta so it's just an
easy way to remember it
by words all right so
so if you use this thing what does it
give us
so you see uh
just written uh by itself it really
gives
up it really doesn't help us okay so
we have this vector and if we just
substitute here you get instead of one
term you get two terms so
what good does it do us well what we are
going to do
is directly do with the first method of
learning this
displacement potential okay so so
all this while what we have been writing
is something very general
and now we are we are we are boiling it
down to something very specific
which is the hemols displacement
potential and what we see in this
in this particular way of displacement
potential the hemol displacement
potential
is that we considered the divergence of
this omega to be equal to zero
okay this is very very important
so you take this
we take the divergence of the omega
vector
to be equal to zero okay do not forget
this
if we have this then
the curl of the curl of the omega vector
it simply reduces to minus
laplacian of omega
which means that
the curl of the displacement vector
is minus laplacian of omega
okay so what we have in our hand now is
an expression for the divergence
okay so this is this is what it is
this thing
and we also have this thing
now what we are going to do
is to take up
this previous equation
here uh
but before i do that uh i notice that
there is a missing term here this row b
is missing so i'll have to make a
correction for that
sorry about that
rho b is equal to zero
i'm going to use this equation
and directly take it from here
now note that i have this
del square u vector here okay so
again by using the same vector identity
that i had used in the previous page
this time written in terms of the u
vector i have the curl of
the curl of u equal to
the grad or the gradient of the
divergence of u
minus the divergence of the gradient of
u which is basically the laplacian of
u so which means that i basically have
laplacian of u is equal to
grad of the divergence
of u minus the curl of the curl of u
if i substitute this expression back
here what i obtain
just substituting this here
g grad divergence of u minus g
curl of the curl of u
plus rho b is equal to 0
and of course you see that this is the
same term which is sitting here
so we can take that common so we have
lambda plus twice g
grad of the divergence of u
minus g
curl of the curl of u and now
in this particular equation we have the
divergence of u
and as well as the curl of u and please
note
uh that in the previous page here
i had already obtained these two
expressions the divergence of u was the
laplacian of phi and the curl of u was
the laplacian of
omega okay so i'll use that here
lambda plus twice g
grad the plus n of pi
so this is minus g curl of the curl of u
now curl of u is the minus
of the laplacian omega so minus and
minus becomes a plus
so this becomes g of
the laplacian of omega vector
plus rho b
all right so now that we have this
equation in terms
of the potential functions
one may easily question that or one may
naturally question
that what is the use of this because
as written it does seem more complicated
than the original equation
so how how how does this help us in
actually solving the problem
if we are making our life more difficult
than it already was originally
okay and and that's an absolutely valid
point
so
and and to really appreciate it please
note that suppose you were supplied with
a with a certain
row b vector how do you actually obtain
the
the three unknowns omega nulls the
the three components of the omega vector
and this
scalar potential phi it's actually
difficult
however if you consider a special case
okay even more special than this that
that uh that rho b okay so considered
rho b equal to 0 okay so this is a very
special case
when you have row b equal to 0 you'll
see that certain simplifications are
possible and then
we'll be able to appreciate the benefit
of going down this
route okay but at the same time let us
not forget
let us not forget that
we have already assumed
this that the divergence of omega vector
is equal to zero
so uh so the equation that we are going
to work with from now on
is this
lambda plus twice g
grad of the laplacian of phi
plus g
curl of the laplacian
of omega is equal to zero
now suppose on this equation so now our
our objective is to is to make some
simplification so that we'll be able to
actually use or to solve for this
okay so you take the divergence of this
so what happens then so we are
considering this lambda and g to be
constants
so if we take the laplacian of or the
divergence of this
we have
divergence operating on this grad
and here we have
this thing so first of all you note that
despite the complicated looking
structure here
uh you can think uh
or perhaps you can expect that these
operators
they commute among themselves okay so
i shouldn't be saying commute among
themselves but at least what you can
what you can see here is that this
divergence which is sitting completely
outside
that will be ultimately operating on
this thing
okay and we have already seen that
divergence
of the omega that is considered to be
equal to zero
so uh this entire term goes to zero
okay so uh i would suggest
that i suggest that you that you
actually try to prove this thing that
the way that this thing is written it
can be equivalently written
as the curl of the laplacian of the
divergence of omega okay so basically
what i'm saying is that you can take
this divergence operator
inside here so that it operates directly
on this
omega vector okay so this entire term
is zero since
divergence of omega is equal to zero so
what we are left with from here
of course i have this lambda plus twice
c here
i ultimately have that the laplacian
of the laplacian of phi that is equal to
zero
which basically means that
i have the bi harmonic of pi
is equal to zero this is an important
statement
okay and this gives you an idea that
okay now this
is somewhat uh we can attempt to solve
this thing
but what about the omega that is still
left
okay you know that we have managed to
obtain something for phi
but what about this omega for that let
us
uh take the uh let us try to take the
curl of this thing okay you take the
curd
so let's say this equation is
hash to take the divergence of hash here
and now take the
world of hash
so this is lambda plus twice g
curl of the gradient
of this thing
plus g
of this entire thing
first of all you note that this phi is
scalar the laplacian of pi
is a scalar so this is basically the
gradient of the scalar
and we already know that the curl
of the gradient of the scalar is
identically zero
in the next step all that you have to
worry about is this thing
now please note that this is again in
the form curl
of the curl of a vector why is it a
vector because you see omega vector of
course is affected and the laplacian of
a vector
is again a vector so this is basically
the curl of the curl of the vector
and the and the moment we realize that
we can again go on and use our our uh
vector identity on this particular thing
so we are going to use the vectoring on
this so
this becomes basically so curl of the
kernel of a vector is basically the
the gradient of the divergence
of that vector the vector that we are
considering is the laplacian of
omega vector minus the
the divergence of the grad of that
vector so which is basically the
laplacian
of that vector that vector is the
laplacian of omega
vector okay and again you note
that this divergence it is going to
operate on this
so that is going to be equal to zero
so ultimately what we have from here is
that
the by harmonic of omega
vector is equal to zero
so earlier we had obtained that the bi
harmonic of phi
is equal to 0 now we are obtaining that
the bi-harmonic of omega is equal to 0
and these are these these two equations
are
these are the two important
simplifications which we obtain
very carefully note that we obtain these
things under the consideration
that first of all the divergence of
omega vector has to be equal to zero
furthermore the body forces have to be
zero and only then
the general m hoods representation of
the displacement vector in terms of the
scalar potential and the vector
potential
they give us these kinds of
simplifications and we can actually try
to
solve for this okay so
this kind of a representation is good
but as you see
uh they they are uh they suffer from
certain kinds of
restrictions okay notably that uh first
of all i mean you can you can do this
only if the body forces at
zero so the thing that we're going to
consider next
we'll we'll see that uh how we can
perhaps
move up a step from this kind of
representation to something of something
slightly different
uh but which is uh which has uh
historically been
uh quite widely used all right so on
that note i'll
i'll end this uh lecture so uh
before just ending i'll i'll make a note
that all of these discussions
as i had pointed out earlier is
basically to provide a step-by-step
approach to ultimately something which
will develop
uh or what will present towards the
solution of the kelvins problem
all right thank you very much
foreign
you